[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Great.
So we'll get started.
Annie Duke has devoted her
life to the study of decision
making under pressure.
During her career as a
professional poker player,
she won over $4
million in tournaments,
earned a World Series
of Poker bracelet,
and is the only woman to have
won the World Series of Poker
Tournament of Champions
and the NBC National Heads
Up Poker Championship.
Retired from poker
since 2012, she
is now a corporate
speaker and a consultant
on decision strategy.
Merging her poker expertise
and her graduate-level research
in psychology at the
University of Pennsylvania,
she has authored five books, is
a co-founder of howIdecide.org,
serves on the board of
After-School All-Stars,
and is a trustee of
The Franklin Institute.
She's also won a
televised championship
in rock paper scissors.
[LAUGHTER]
Was that a high-stakes game
of rock paper scissors?
ANNIE DUKE: I think
I won, like, $10,000.
SPEAKER 1: I would
say high stakes, yeah.
[LAUGH]
A mom of four, and she
lives outside Philadelphia.
So let's welcome her to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
So Annie, you want to
start with what inspired
you to write this book?
ANNIE DUKE: Oh.
Oh, that's a very
broad question.
So I used to joke--
the joke that I used
to make was for most
of my professional
career, I spent my life
taking advantage
of people who made
decisions that weren't so good.
So maybe I should spend some
of my life trying to help
people make better decisions.
So that's kind of
the cheeky answer.
But I think that what
actually really inspired
me to write the book
was that I started off
my life in academics.
I was at the University
of Pennsylvania.
I was studying
cognitive science.
Which is really, of
course, a study of the way
that our brains interact
with the environment.
How do we process
information as it comes in?
I was getting my PhD in
that, had a National Science
Foundation Fellowship,
and I was on my way
to become a professor.
And right at the end of that
journey, I actually got sick.
I ended up with a stomach
problem that landed me
in the hospital for
a couple of weeks,
and I ended up missing the
job market for that year,
because it's seasonal.
So I had to take time
off just to recuperate,
and I was going to go back out
on the market the next year,
and I ended up in
that year, that's
when I took what felt like this
very big left turn into poker.
So I started playing poker,
and about eight years into it,
I got asked by actually a
retreat of options traders
if I could come speak
to them about the way
that poker might inform
their decision making
and how they handle risk.
And it was this moment where I
realized, you know, oh, gosh.
I thought I took this
really huge left turn out
of academics, but I didn't.
I landed in just a really
amazing natural laboratory
to study, how do we make
decisions under conditions
of uncertainty when the
outcomes of those decisions
are not very well
connected to the quality
of the decision making itself?
It's just a very
noisy environment.
And how are you
pulling the signal
out, and how are you learning
under those circumstances?
And the answer is,
not so well, really.
And it was this moment of
kind of revelation for me
as I was thinking,
like, what am I going
to say to this group of people?
Because it was this kind
of moment where it all
came together for
me where I said,
you know, it's
really interesting,
because I was taught
in graduate school
that learning occurs under
conditions where you have
lots and lots of feedback tied
closely in time to decisions
and actions.
And as I'm going to go talk to
these people, what I realize
is poker is the ultimate
lots and lots of feedback
tied closely in time.
I mean, within 30 seconds of
time to decisions and actions.
And yet what I saw was
that learning was not
occurring very well.
And so it was that moment of
wanting to square those two
things together.
And after that first
talk, I just went--
I was like, oh.
And I started building
this second career
and speaking to audiences
about how poker's
kind of a really great
platform and framework for kind
of understanding not only what
are the problems in decision
making, but how can we
kind of solve for them?
And I sort of feel
like from 2002
I was just workshopping
this material,
and that I was finding this
incredible joy in sharing
these ideas with people
in a way that felt really
different to me than poker.
In poker, I'm thinking about
these ideas in a way that's
very zero sum, right?
I'm going to win,
you're going to lose.
You're going to win,
I'm going to lose.
And you know, when I
started doing this in 2002,
I started growing
that business, and it
started to become a much
bigger part of my life,
actually, than the poker was.
And it just felt in
this really nice way
like I was adding water
sort of back into the ocean.
And you know, this book sort of
came out of that whole journey
that I took.
SPEAKER 1: So can we talk
about what prevents people
from making good decisions?
ANNIE DUKE: Oh, that's--
because that's that--
do we want to narrow
that down at all?
What prevents people from
making good decisions?
I think it's a collision
of a couple of problems.
I think that the first
piece is uncertainty,
and uncertainty comes
from two places.
It comes from
hidden information.
So this is where we
can see how poker
might be a really good way
to look at decision making.
The first place it comes
from is hidden information.
So in poker, the
cards are face down.
Guess what?
In life as well.
There's very often a lot of
information asymmetry, right?
And there's lots of
stuff that we can't know,
and there's lots of
things that we don't know.
So that's the first place
that uncertainty comes from.
But even if we did have perfect
information-- say, for example,
about a coin, and we
know that heads or tails,
it's going to flip
50% of the time,
we also have the intervention
of luck, which is
the other form of uncertainty.
So even if I know everything
I need to know about the coin
so there's no hidden information
about the coin, that doesn't
mean I can predict
whether it will flip
heads or tails on next try.
I can say something
over 10,000 tries.
I can tell you how it's
going to work out over time.
But most of what we're
doing is actually
sort of these
one-trial scenarios.
And particularly as we're trying
to make decisions and learn
from the outcomes
of our decisions,
we're not very good aggregators.
So we're not sitting back--
well, first of all, most
of the decisions we make,
we couldn't get
10,000 trials even so.
But even if we could, the data's
kind of coming in one at a time
as we're out sort
of in the field,
making our own decisions.
And so we're sort of encoding
everything one at a time.
We're not sitting back
and saying, let me not
make any decisions until I
have lots and lots of data.
And in fact, that
would be impractical,
because for example,
you would never,
say, get married to
somebody then, right?
Because you'd have
to get so many trials
in order to know
that you were sure.
So it's not practical
to do anyway.
So the first piece,
the first problem
is that there's all
this uncertainty.
And then the second
problem is that nature,
the way that our
brains are built
has given us a lot of rope
to sort of hang ourselves
with the uncertainty.
And we can sort
of go back to sort
of the beginning,
which is, what are
the types of errors that
evolution built us to make?
So there are a type 1
errors and type 2 errors.
Type 1 errors are false
positives and type 2 errors
are false negatives.
And we're really, really
built for false positives.
We connect things together,
we think they're causal,
we think they go together much
more often than they actually
do.
So we're big at patterns.
We love things to be
connected together,
and that causes a problem.
So that's sort of
problem number one.
And we can think about
that in the sense of,
which is worse, if you're on the
savanna and you hear rustling,
you know, among
the reeds, are you
going to wait and see, oh, let
me try to figure out if there's
actually a lion here?
Or are you going to run away?
Right?
So obviously, we're
going to run away.
So that's number one.
Number two is we're
built for tribes.
So there was a lot
of advantage for us
surviving if we came together
in groups and we had tribes.
And so that causes
a problem as well
for decision making, because
it causes these problems
in the way that we process
information from things
that are outside of our tribe.
So that's kind of the
number two problem.
And then the number
three problem is really,
I talk about this
a lot in the book
is that we aren't really
built to disconfirm the things
that we already believe.
We're very much built
to affirm our priors.
And so when you think about the
uncertainty and the way that we
sort of interpret
information as it comes in,
there's so much
uncertainty in the data
that we're getting that it gives
us the room to just process
the world in a way to make us
feel right about the things
that we already believe.
And when you have that
collision between that,
the false positive problem
and then the tribal problem
on top of that, things
really fall apart.
SPEAKER 1: Now your book-- you
were talking about this belief
people have about showing the
right information to people,
and somehow it will get them
to see things correctly.
Can you talk more
about that too?
ANNIE DUKE: Sure.
So I think that this
is part of the problem
is that we have these ways
that we process information.
So an example that I
talk about in my book
is something called
motivated reasoning.
So I think you've all probably
heard about confirmation bias.
So motivated reasoning
is a larger problem
than confirmation bias.
So in confirmation bias, we
have some sort of prior belief,
and we'll notice stuff
that confirms the belief,
and we just kind of
won't notice things
that disconfirm the belief.
Motivated reasoning
is, let's think
about this as an umbrella
problem of which confirmation
bias is part, which is that
we actually are motivated
to confirm the beliefs we have,
and that drives our information
processing.
So that means that
not only will we
sort of notice stuff
that confirms us and not
notice things that
disconfirm us,
but also when confronted
with information
that disconfirms
us, we work very,
very hard to discredit it.
And when confronted with
information that confirms us,
we actually don't put any effort
into the discrediting at all.
So we don't really
vet it very hard.
And you guys can probably
feel that, right?
When I read an article that,
say, politically agrees
with me, I'm like, wow.
That's a really smart article.
[LAUGHTER]
And when it disagrees with
me politically, I am like,
you know, they're looking at the
study and the N is too small,
and they weren't
looking at this data,
and they were asking
the wrong questions,
and the person isn't
reliable anyway,
and they forgot all
this other stuff,
and they're totally biased.
And you know, it's
weird, because I just
don't go through that
process with the things that
agree with me.
Strange.
OK.
So not only that.
Then we have this
other issue, which
is that when we're in a tribe,
part of what a tribe gives
you is kind of forth-- it gives
you a sense of belongingness,
a sense of
distinctiveness, right?
So you belong to a tribe.
You're distinct from other
tribes in some way where you
process that as being superior.
It gives you the idea
of sort of what's moral
and what's not is also
included in the tribe.
But then it also gives you
something really important
for this talk today, which
is called epistemic closure,
meaning that the
tribe is telling you
what knowledge is true and
trustworthy and what is not.
So I think that a lot of
times what we sort of think--
and this is where we understand
this, the motivated reasoning
with the collision of
the tribal problem.
What we sort of think is, oh.
If other people just
had the information,
we'd all be fine, because
then we'd all sort of
believe the same things.
Right?
So if we were all working with
the exact same information,
we'd all be good.
But that's assuming that
we live in something--
that we're all living
in epistemic bubbles
versus echo chambers.
So let me just explain
what the difference is.
An epistemic bubble is
you have information
and you don't have other
information, period.
So if you're in
an epidemic bubble
where you just haven't
gotten the information,
then if you get exposed to the
information, you incorporate it
and you're all good.
But epistemic bubbles
are pretty rare.
What we mostly live
in is echo chambers.
So echo chambers are, it
doesn't matter whether we
have the information or not.
People outside the group
are not trusted sources.
So if you get information
that disagrees
with you that's coming from
someone outside the group,
it's not trusted anyway.
And you can see how
you can use that
in order to accomplish the
goals in motivated reasoning.
So when you're now
confronted with information
that disagrees with you, one
of the ways you discredit it
is to talk about the
trustworthiness of the source.
So you know, what we want to
be really careful about is
we want to try to apply as
we're trying to imagine--
and I talk about
this in the book--
as we're trying to sort of
vet information that comes in,
we want to apply a particular
norm called universalism, which
is separating the
person who's delivering
the news from whether the
news itself is correct or not.
So the way I put
it in the book is
doesn't really
matter whether it's
Copernicus or Mussolini
or your mom who tells you
that the Earth is round.
The fact of the
roundness of the Earth
is independent of those sources.
So in order to actually
be good universalists,
it's usually pretty
good as you're
sort of having these
reactions to information
to try to imagine it
absent of the source,
or to try to imagine it
being delivered from a source
that you actually trust.
And that actually helps
you to vet the information
independently of the source,
which we're really, really,
really bad at, and it's part of
this problem of echo chambers.
SPEAKER 1: So you were
talking about systems
of how we can overcome
that and looking
at decisions in terms of bets.
Could you talk more about that?
ANNIE DUKE: Sure.
Yeah.
So the book is called
"Thinking in Bets."
And the premise is that if we
were more explicit in imagining
or in actually just making clear
that every decision that we
make is a bet, that we would
actually be better off,
and it would create a
lot more open-mindedness.
And why is that?
Well, first of all, let me
try to convince you guys
that every decision is a bet.
So that's the first step.
So actually, I'll
tell a story that I
tell in here, which is kind
of a fun story, I think.
So there was a guy named John
Hennigan, a really, really,
really great poker player
known to have a lot of gamble.
And in the '90s, when he was
in his 20s, he was really--
if you were to think
about, what is a--
if you imagined a stereotype
of a poker player in 1995,
John Hennigan would be the guy.
Like, he never saw the sun.
He was only playing at night.
He was a total action junkie.
Like, when he was finished
at the poker table,
he just wanted to gamble more.
Like, he was really--
he was very good, but he
really liked a lot of action.
So he was sitting at
a poker table one day,
and a discussion broke
out about state capitals,
and people were quizzing
each other on state capitals.
So Des Moines comes up.
And John Hennigan actually
announces at the table
as they're discussing Des
Moines, oh, I could totally
live in Des Moines.
And you know, Des
Moines obviously,
reputation is kind of sleepy.
Maybe if you were to
think about sort of,
what's the antithesis
of Las Vegas,
maybe you would think of
Des Moines as an example.
So the players at the table
were like, oh, come on.
Like, there's no way you
could live from Des Moines.
But Hennigan actually
at that time in his life
was sort of thinking, like, oh.
You know, I never see
the sun, and so maybe it
would be really nice to go
and sort of detox from Vegas
a little bit.
And then he also
had another thing
in mind, which is that poker
players gamble on golf a lot.
And he thought, well,
then I could actually
really spend some time on
golf without the distraction
of the actual poker.
So they negotiate a bet.
So at the table,
they negotiate a bet
that John Hennigan's going to
move to Las Vegas for 30 days--
I mean, to Des Moines,
rather, for 30 days.
They add a little bit of a
diabolical condition, which
is the hotel that he's
on is only one street,
and there's only one
restaurant on the street.
And there's, like, no
bars, there's no nightlife,
there's nothing.
He's confined to the one
street when he moves there
for the 30 days, except
there is a specific golf
course he's allowed to go to to
practice golf during the day.
So they settle on 30 days, and
the bet is set for $30,000.
So if he can stay in Las Vegas
for 30 days, he wins $30,000.
If he can't stay
there and he has
to come back from
Des Moines, then he's
going to lose $30,000.
So literally the next day,
he moved to Des Moines.
So two days later, he
calls up the group.
And he says, hey.
I'm in Des Moines.
I'm obviously, like--
I've completely up
and moved to Des Moines.
Clearly, I'm good to go.
I'm going to stay here.
So if you'd like to settle,
you guys can pay me $15,000
and I'll come home,
and I'll save you
the misery of losing
the whole $30,000.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that was the
group's reaction.
So they were like, no.
We're good, John.
You know, why don't
you stay there?
So a week later, John Hennigan
had moved back from Des Moines,
he was living in Las Vegas,
and he had paid the group
$15,000 for the privilege.
So I tell this story because
it sounds like, oh my gosh.
These crazy poker
players making this bet
on where John was going to move.
But if you think
about it, it's really
no different than any decision
that you've ever made.
I mean, your decision to come
and work at Google, right?
You have other opportunities.
You're thinking about what--
John has to think about, am
I going to like Des Moines?
He doesn't know, because he
hasn't lived there before,
right?
The money that I'm going
to make if I win this bet,
is it going to be
better than the money
that I'm going to make
if I stay in Las Vegas?
And if I'm actually
taking less money,
is that OK, because I'm
creating different types
of opportunities for myself?
Like, I'm going to
feel like I live
a healthier life for
that month, and that's
worth making less money.
Or I'm going to work
on my golf game,
and that's going
to have payoffs.
Which would be sort
of the same as, I'm
thinking about taking
a job in Des Moines,
and I have to think
about, how is Des Moines
going to compare to the
place that I live now?
I don't know.
I've never lived there.
Am I going to like it
versus any other place
that I might possibly move?
Is the salary good
enough for me to feel
like I'm willing to
take that risk in terms
of going and moving there?
What are the opportunities
for advancement?
What other kinds
of money, you know,
could I make in the future?
And when you choose
to move to Des Moines
or relocate or take
the job at Google,
you're obviously forgoing
all other possibilities
available to you.
You can only make
the one decision,
which was true for
John Hennigan as well.
So basically, Hennigan had a
certain set of beliefs about
whether or not he would like
Des Moines, whether or not
it would be worth it to him.
And when he made
the choice, he was
foregoing all other choices,
including staying in Las Vegas
and staying with the status quo,
or moving any other place where
he might maybe detox or go, you
know, detox from the nightlife
or go and practice his golf,
or whatever it might be.
And there was a whole set
of possible futures that
could occur from
that, one where he
stayed in Des Moines for
30 days and loved it,
one where he loved Des Moines
so much he never moved back,
one where he met the love
of his life in Des Moines.
You know, one where he calls
up after two days and says,
hey, I want to settle.
And the thing is
that you don't know.
You're making an estimation of
what the probability of each
of those futures
might be, and you're
deciding that whatever
you have to invest--
and it doesn't have to be money.
It can be your health,
your happiness, your time,
whatever it might be.
Usually, it's all of the above.
Whatever you're
investing in the decision
that you actually
go with, that that's
going to hurtle you to the
best set of possible futures
as compared to any other
decision that you might make.
So the poker players really
just make that explicit.
And that's really what you're
doing when you're betting
is you're making it
explicit that a decision is
a bet informed by your beliefs
on a set of possible futures
that you might be
hurtling yourself to.
So once we kind of
understand that frame,
I think that it
actually can help
us overcome some
of these problems
that we have with
decision making.
And I'll show you a
really simple example.
So here's something that's
been in the news a lot lately,
because I hear it every
single day on the news.
The Democrats are going to
take the House in the fall.
So OK.
So let's say that
you said to me,
the Democrats are going to
win the House in the fall.
And let's say that
my response was,
do you want to bet on that?
So think for yourselves,
what does that do to you?
It causes you to retreat
from a place of certainty
into a place of probabilistic
thinking, right?
Because now what you start
to think is, OK, well, wait.
Why do I think that?
Ooh, there's a lot of time
between now and November.
There's a lot of things
that could happen, right?
Like, Trump could
solve North Korea.
I don't know.
That might change things, right?
We don't know.
There's all sorts
of other things
that might happen with Trump.
Trump is somewhat unpredictable.
There are things that could
happen with the Democrats.
You know, I mean,
the number of things
that can intervene on
the luck side between now
and six months from now
is pretty large, right?
And so you'll start
to think about that.
It brings-- it bubbles that
uncertainty up to the fore.
And then you also
start to think, well,
have I been reading opinions
that disagree with that?
Like, what does the person
who's challenging me to the bet
know or think that
I haven't thought of
or that I don't know?
I have to start thinking
about, why might I be wrong
here before I'm willing to
actually put that kind of skin
into the game, right?
And so essentially,
what this element of,
let me think about my decisions
explicitly as bets does
is it forces you into more
probabilistic thinking,
into more the recognizing of
these two forms of uncertainty.
That I don't ever have
perfect information for pretty
much anything, right?
We just don't.
And that the future
is always uncertain.
That no matter how well
I think about the future
or how much I
predict the future,
even if the only bad outcome
can occur 1% of the time,
it can still happen.
So I need to think
about that as I'm
sort of announcing these
things with certainty.
Once you start to bubble up
the uncertainty in any decision
that you make, it causes you
to be much more open-minded.
Because now what happens is
that you're thinking about,
well, if I can
only think about--
if my beliefs are probabilistic
and my predictions
about the future
are probabilistic,
then I need to be
information hungry.
Because what I need to do
is start refining my beliefs
and refining my predictions,
because I actually
have to bet on these things
with things like my time
and things like my money
and things like my health,
and these limited
resources that I have.
And if I can only make
one decision at a time
and I'm thinking about
this probabilistically,
I'd better start
really working to try
to refine all of this stuff.
And how am I going to do that?
Well, it's going to cause me
to be open-minded in particular
to why I'm wrong.
Open-minded to opinions and
beliefs that disagree with me,
because I already
know why I'm right.
That's how I got to a place of
certainty in the first place.
So once I start
backing off of that,
I've got to start
thinking about, again,
what does the other person
know that I don't know?
And I think that that's why it's
such a good frame for trying
to solve for some
of these problems.
SPEAKER 1: So you
make the bet and it
doesn't work out for you.
Like, what should
your next steps
be on how to analyze
what happened?
ANNIE DUKE: So you make the
bet and it doesn't work out
for you, right?
And so what should
your next steps be?
So that's a very good question.
So actually, one
of the big problems
is that once you have
a result, it really
distorts your ability to go
back in and analyze the decision
process.
It's a problem called resulting.
So another story from
the book that I'll
give to sort of
illustrate this problem,
and then we can talk
about solutions for this,
so do you guys
remember the 2015 Super
Bowl, Seahawks versus Patriots?
Yeah.
So you're in the right area
to remember that, right?
OK.
So it's the last play
of the Super Bowl.
The Seahawks are on the
1-yard line, 26 seconds left.
It's second down.
They have one time-out,
and they're down by 4.
So this is obviously a
really important decision
that's going on here,
because if they score,
the Patriots are unlikely
to have enough time
to be able to march back down
the field and score again.
So if they can get
a touchdown here,
this probably would
even be the game winner,
which would be a
really big deal,
because the Patriots never lose
the Super Bowl until this year.
And I'm from Philly, but we'll--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just saying, I was
pretty excited about that.
So OK.
So what is Pete Carroll do here?
He's got a running back on
his team named Marshawn Lynch.
Amazing short
yardage running back.
Everybody's expecting him to
hand it off to Marshawn Lynch.
And instead, he calls pass play.
Russell Wilson passes
the ball, and the ball
is intercepted pretty
famously, and boom.
Done.
Malcolm Butler
intercepts the ball.
The game is over.
The end game calling
from Cris Collinsworth
is pretty brutal
on this decision.
You know, Pete Carroll, I
can't even believe this call.
This is such a horrible call.
And the next day, I have to
say that most of the pundits
did not disagree.
There seemed to be an
argument among major outlets
about whether it was the worst
call in Super Bowl history,
which was most of them.
But "USA Today" actually said it
was the worst call in football
history, period.
So that seems to be where
the disagreement lay.
So this is a really good
example of resulting.
So we know what-- the
result was horrible, right?
I mean, the result was one of
the worst results in Super Bowl
history.
We can agree on that.
But that does not
mean that it was
one of the worst decisions
in Super Bowl history.
And I think to just declare
that Pete Carroll hadn't
put any thought into it, I
mean, this is Pete Carroll.
He's in the Super
Bowl for a reason.
You know, that was
pretty spectacular.
So like, I'll just ask you
guys to do a thought experiment
so we can see what
the problem is.
What do you do once
you have the result?
Imagine that Pete Carroll
passes that ball and the ball
is caught for a touchdown
in the end zone.
Just take a moment
to think about that.
Now how does that
decision feel now?
Brilliant.
But how it turns out
on that one outcome
shouldn't actually
affect the way
that we think about
the decision, right?
I mean, that's like saying if I
flip a coin and you call heads
and it lands heads, that that
was a brilliant decision.
But if it lands tails, that
was a really dumb decision.
Like, one outcome
tells us nothing.
But you can feel it.
You can feel it.
Like, the result acts
like a gravity well.
And you can't climb out of it
to look at whether the decision
process was good or not.
It's really hard.
Now just to not leave you with
a cliffhanger, just so you know,
the probability of an
interception in that spot
depends on how many seasons
you aggregate across,
but it's probably somewhere
hovering around 1% or 2%.
Right?
So here they declared this
the worst decision ever,
and like a 1 percenter
hit basically.
So I don't think
that should really
say very much about whether
the quality of that decision
was any good.
Also, by the way, for anybody
who understands options theory,
remember they only
had one time-out.
So if [INAUDIBLE] I think
it's about 40% of the time
that the ball just
isn't complete there.
What happens?
The ball stops.
And guess what
they have time for?
Two running plays.
So if they hand the ball
off to Marshawn Lynch,
they're going to run so
much time out that they're
only to be able to
get two plays off,
even with being able
to call the time-out,
so they're only going
to get two plays.
If they pass the ball
and it's dropped,
they actually get
three plays, including
those two running plays
that everybody wanted
them to run in the first place.
So it's a somewhat free option.
It costs you this
interception rate of about 1%.
For a more detailed
analysis, Benjamin Morris
on FiveThirtyEight
has a great one.
Highly recommend you go read it.
But so this is where
we can see that once we
know the outcome, once we
know whether it's good or bad,
it's incredibly hard for us not
to then retrofit the decision
quality to the outcome.
So the answer is unless you're
running a Monte Carlo, which
we can't for most
things, what do
we do once an outcome
has occurred in terms of,
how do we move forward?
It's like, ignore the
outcome as much as possible
is actually the
weird answer to that.
And I understand it's
counterintuitive,
but it's kind of the
only way to move forward.
It's like, OK.
It was one outcome.
I've got to think about the
decision in absence of that.
And if you want, we can
talk about strategies
for doing that.
SPEAKER 1: That would be great.
Because you mentioned
Phil Ivey as one side
of looking at every situation.
Look at the skill aspect of it.
What can I control?
What can I improve?
And then you have Hellmuth
who, I guess his quote is,
"I would be the best
poker player of all time
if it wasn't for luck."
ANNIE DUKE: Yes.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: So maybe we can
talk about that spectrum
and strategies.
ANNIE DUKE: Sure.
So there's only two
things that determine
the way our lives turn
out, luck and the quality
of our decisions.
So we can't really
control the luck element,
so we should try to
get down and focus
on the quality of the decision.
So you mentioned Phil Ivey I
think as a really good example
part of the way to do this.
So I tell a story about-- he
won a really huge tournament
against really an
all-star final table.
Phil Ivey is one of the best
poker players in history.
And he actually went to
dinner with my brother,
and he spent the whole time
talking about all the mistakes
that he had made.
So obviously, he's got
an interesting cognitive
style, probably
one that's partly
responsible for how good he is.
But he gives us actually
a clue of how to handle
these kinds of situations.
So there's a variety
of different--
what we're trying to
do is get to a point
where we can all be Phil Ivey.
It's very hard to do.
It's very hard to sort of
take our great outcomes
and look for mistakes.
It's very hard to take our bad
outcomes, actually, and look
for mistakes as well.
We kind of want to pawn
that off onto luck.
So what I really talk
about in the book
is that the way into
this is actually
to try to separate outcomes
from decision quality
as much as possible.
So how can we do that?
There's a variety of
ways we can do that.
Let's talk sort of
strategy number one.
All of this is done much
better in a group, by the way,
and part of that reason is
because of this kind of gravity
well that we end up down in.
This is the way our brains work.
It's very hard for us
to parse this apart.
But other people
can see our bias
much better than we can
see it in ourselves.
I mean, you can spot bias
thinking a mile away, right?
So like, get some
people in a group
with you who will
spot your bias,
and you'll spot their bias.
And then here are
some things that you
can do with that group.
Thing number one is when
possible, deconstruct decisions
before outcomes have occurred.
So that's really,
really good to do.
And memorialize it.
So now as you're thinking
about the decision
and what the outcomes
might be, you
can write down what you think
all the possible outcomes are.
So we can think about this
in terms of the Pete Carroll
example.
And there's like, OK.
Maybe the ball will be caught.
Maybe the ball will be dropped.
Maybe it will be intercepted.
You try to assign some
sort of probability
to each of those
possible scenarios.
You think about what the extra
things you're getting out of it
are.
So what is the
payoff in that case?
I'm getting two
running plays anyway.
So now what happens is that
when the ball gets intercepted,
you know, you're not
overreacting to it,
because you've actually
thought about this in advance,
and you can actually
point and say,
well, there's the
interception scenario.
We thought about that when we
thought about the decision,
and it happens 1% of the time.
So let's not overreact
to that and go now change
our decision the way that
we decide in the future
to not call that play again,
because it's already up there.
So like, a trial lawyer
can deconstruct their trial
strategy before they
get, you know, a verdict.
So that's one thing you can do.
When possible, do
as much of the work
before you get the outcome.
That's really good.
Now in poker that's actually,
like, literally impossible,
because you get the
outcome in 30 seconds.
So there's not a lot of work
you can do in that 30 seconds,
and you certainly can't
go off to a group and say,
can we work out
the decision tree,
and then I'll come
back to the table
and actually make my decision?
So you can't do that.
So in that case, what
you can do is when you go
and you work with whatever
your truth seeking group
is that you've sort
of formed together,
the people that you deconstruct
decisions with, only
describe the hand or the
question or the decision
up to the point that you
need help, and no further.
So like, an example I could
give from poker would be, OK.
I've got to hand.
You know, let's say
I have king, queen.
And I open the pot for a raise,
and this other guy re-raises,
and he's very aggressive,
and he actually raises a lot.
And so I was trying to
decide, should I fold?
Or maybe I should re-raise him.
What do you think?
So notice, I don't--
I know how the hand turned out.
I know how the person responded.
I know I would give a lot
more detail than that leading
up to that, but I know
exactly what happened.
But if I'm asking you,
I'm not telling you.
Because our own bias, these
problems are infectious.
So once I tell you the
way it turned out, like,
let's say that I told you,
so I decided to re-raise
and you then moved
all in on me, you're
going to now make a
story that makes sense,
and you're going to now
tell me about the decision
in a way that's going
to make the fact
that that particular
result happened make sense,
because that's just the
way our minds like to work.
So I'm just going
to leave it out,
and I'm only going to
tell you to the point
that I have a decision.
So that's one thing I can do.
Another thing I can
do is to one person,
I can tell you it
worked out well.
And to another person, I can
tell them it worked out poorly.
So I can change the story's end.
I think that's a really
interesting exercise
to do, because
you will be amazed
at how different the
analyses you get,
what the advice looks like
from the person you tell
that it ended well
versus the person
that you tell it ended poorly.
And I think that
then you can sort of
look at those two
things and kind of work
to merge them together
in order to get
some fidelity in your ability
to actually understand
what the decision quality is.
So that's another way that you
can sort of not infect people.
And you can do this
in a variety of ways,
not just with outcomes,
but with your own beliefs.
So here's a really simple-- so
there's a simple problem, which
is like, if you allow people
to talk to each other,
they sort of try to
come to consensus
and make beliefs make sense,
and you're infecting everybody
with your beliefs.
So here's an example.
Let's say that you
have four people who
have interviewed somebody that
you're thinking about hiring.
Don't let them
talk to each other.
Make them give you
their opinions,
write down their
opinions separately.
Because once they
talk to each other,
you've literally infected.
It's like a virus.
Another thing is, let's
say that you're now
in front of
everybody, and you've
gotten the advice from
people, and now you
want to start talking in
the room about the advice.
Do not say who you think should
be hired, because that'll
ruin the whole thing, right?
So keep your own
beliefs to yourself
when you're trying to get
advice from other people.
And this is a simple--
like, in everyday life,
I read an article on politics.
If I'm asking you what your
opinion of the article is,
I should not say what
my belief about that
is, because then I've
ruined the whole thing.
So I think that that's really
what you should do with it,
is kind of like, unless you've
got a large enough N, which
is rare, you should
kind of leave it out.
Where do outcomes help you?
Well, you know, obviously
throughout your life
as you kind of get them in,
they might be prompts for you
to go in and say,
well, maybe I should
look at the decision quality.
But it should be-- both
in the case of whether you
won or lost, it should be
a prompt to go in and look
at the decision quality.
And when you go in and look
at the decision quality
and you want to talk to
other people about it,
you're going to do
better because you've
been prompted by the outcome
to leave the outcome out
as you're going to actually
improve the decision quality.
It's a little counterintuitive.
SPEAKER 1: Is there
are some situations
where just sitting out,
not making the decision
makes sense?
Because you mentioned that
most poker players-- like,
80% of the hands, they
don't make any actions on,
and there's only
20% that they play?
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah,
so in poker, one
of the biggest mistakes
that people make
is actually playing
way too many hands.
And you always need to think
about when you're actually
going to enter into something,
you need to be selective.
So I want to talk about sort
of both sides of this puzzle.
One is that just doing
stuff isn't enough.
Like, I think a
lot of times people
are like, just throw a lot of
spaghetti against the wall.
But you should actually
think about each strand
and make sure you're getting
a payoff for the strand.
So the fact is, yes.
If you throw a bunch of
spaghetti against the wall,
some of that will pay
off and some of it won't.
And I think that people look
at that, and they look at,
for example, VCs and they think
that's what their strategy is,
that they're just sort
of playing every hand,
and then some of them pay off.
And you know, when they pay
off, they're really heavy.
But that's not true.
They are spreading their
bets across a large basket,
but they're actually
vetting each of the bets
that they're making to make
sure that given what they know,
they think that the payoff
is going to be big enough.
So that's similar to
what a poker player does.
So that's number one.
But then number two that I think
is really important to think
about is that, don't take
that to the point of thinking
that somehow making a
decision is substantively
different from not
making a decision,
because they're both decisions.
So you have whatever
the status quo is.
And when you're
going along and just
kind of going with the
status quo, trust me,
you're making a decision
every single time you do that.
So I think that when we're
trying to sort of think
about doing these scenario
plans and imagining what
the future might look like, we
only think about it in terms
of decisions that we think
are new, where somehow we're
changing course.
But not changing course is
a decision in and of itself.
So you shouldn't be
taking time frequently
to look at what
the status quo is,
to look at what you're
doing, the strategies
that you've always just
kind of been applying,
and do the exact
same kind of analysis
on that as if it
were a new decision.
So let me give you a
super simple example.
This is, like, the
simplest example ever.
You're in a grocery
store, and there's,
you know, six lanes open.
And you're Einstein
at this moment.
Like, you're literally
doing some kind
of quantum physics
analysis about which line
you're supposed to get into.
You're laughing, because
you know it's true.
So it's like, you
know, you're looking
for the lady with the
coupons, and you know,
the cashier that looks
maybe like, you know,
oh, he seems a little slow or
he's new or he's a trainee,
or you know, the person
who has 17,000 things
in their car versus whatever.
I mean, it's literally
like, you are completely
calculating this stuff out.
OK.
So that's a new decision, right?
So you're calculating
out all the scenarios,
trying to figure out,
like, which is going
to give me the best future?
Because you're now
investing your time, right?
So this is very clearly a bet.
You're betting on a line.
And you think that
the you that results
from choosing whatever
line it is that you go to
is going to save time over the
you that results from whatever
other line you might choose.
And that's what most bets are.
You're not betting
against other people.
You're betting against other
versions of yourself, right?
Like, Annie that chooses
line A versus Annie
that chooses line B. Or
like, I'm in the restaurant.
Annie that chooses the chicken
or Annie that uses the fish,
or whatever.
So Annie that chooses Des
Moines versus Annie that
chooses Las Vegas.
OK.
So now you choose a line.
And you get in the line, and
the line turns out to be slow.
What do you do?
You stay in the line.
You don't move.
But it's a new decision.
Like, once you figure out
the line is slow, switch.
But you don't,
because you know why?
Because you're worried
about now if I switch,
what if that line-- my
line starts moving faster?
I'll feel like I made a mistake.
But at any moment,
it's the same decision.
So if you treat the status
quo as if that's not
a decision in and of
itself, what happens is
you actually end up not
changing course enough.
So we can go back to
the Pete Carroll example
to think about this.
Let's do the other
thought experiment
where Pete Carroll just doesn't
change his grocery line, right?
So he hands it off to
Marshawn Lynch, right?
That was the expected play.
That's the status quo play.
And let's say he doesn't score.
What do you think the headlines
look like the next day?
Oh, New England's good.
[LAUGH]
Literally, nobody's
like, oh, he's
the worst coach in
Super Bowl history
because he handed
off to Marshawn Lynch
and he didn't score.
Why?
Because people aren't viewing
that as a decision, right?
Like, that's just
the status quo.
We already have
consensus around that.
Clearly if he doesn't win, then
it's not the decision quality.
Now we can firmly stick
it in the luck bucket,
because nobody's
questioning the status quo.
So now it must be something
that's outside of his control.
So included in luck
would be-- for example,
the quality of the defensive
line of New England
would be included in luck.
Luck is anything that you
yourself don't control.
OK?
And that's because, all right.
He chose his grocery line.
Like, he's not switching.
So the reason why
Pete Carroll got
so demolished in that
decision is because he
switched grocery lines.
But he was right to do that.
Like, that's how
progress gets made.
SPEAKER 1: Mm-hmm.
And I find in our
daily lives too,
sometimes after a
result happens, we'll
look at the person
who made the decision,
and then we'll say to ourselves,
well, if it went their way,
then odds are, it's luck.
But if it would have
failed, it's like, you know,
it's mostly due to their
incompetencies or whatnot.
Is there mechanisms where we
can be more cognizant of that
when we fall into that mode?
I think you talk about--
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah.
So I've talked about this
particularly thing, resulting,
which is where we really tightly
connect outcomes and decisions.
But there's two ways
that we do this.
One is like, we're
looking at someone
from afar like Pete Carroll.
OK, so he's not in our
reference group, right?
Like, we don't compare
ourselves to him.
And so in that case, we
just look like, bad outcome
means bad decision.
Good outcome means
good decision.
So it's interesting, because
we do a pattern for ourselves
that's a little bit different.
So if anybody's read
"Thinking Fast and Slow"
from Daniel Kahneman,
you'll remember this
from this, that
we're really trying
to drive a positive narrative
of our lives, right?
We want to think that
we're good actors
and we're smart, and
so on and so forth.
So obviously, this goes in the
motivated reasoning category,
like, if we have a bad
outcome for ourselves.
If I lose a hand at
poker, that doesn't really
jive with this positive
self-narrative,
at least not in the moment, OK?
So then what do we do?
Now remember, we've got this
noise in the system, right?
We've got the hidden
information and luck.
When I lose a hand at
poker, it's because of luck.
When I win a hand at poker,
it's because I'm a genius.
That's called self-serving bias.
I feel like it's a pretty
self-explanatory name
for that particular bias.
And we do this in all
areas of our lives.
When someone gets a promotion,
you know, it's bad luck for us.
Like, it's not like we didn't
do the work or we didn't-- you
know, obviously, we deserved it.
It was just, like, bad luck.
It wasn't in our control.
Actually, car accidents are
an interesting place to look.
Over 90% of two-car
accidents are
reported as the
other person's fault.
This is a pretty good one.
I think it's 37%, I think,
of single-car accidents
as reported as not the
person's fault. I don't know.
You go figure that one out.
So that's how strong
this bias is, right?
Now what's interesting is--
but the number of decisions
that we make in our lives
is obviously much
less than the number
of decisions we're able to
observe in other people.
So let's assume that, OK,
we're crappy for ourselves,
but it doesn't matter,
because then we get
to feel good about ourselves.
But we're really good at
analyzing everybody else's
decisions.
But the problem is, as soon
as someone's in our reference
group, as soon as it's someone
that we feel like we're
comparing ourselves to,
to sort of figure out what
our self-worth is,
because we don't do that.
Our happiness doesn't
derive an absence of the way
that we compare to other people.
Now what we do is the
reverse pattern, right?
When they do something good,
it's because they got lucky,
and when they do
something bad, it's
because they're a really
bad decision maker.
So when they win
a hand of poker,
it's because they got lucky.
And when they lose
a hand of poker,
it's because they're
a bad decision maker.
Now you can kind
of see, actually,
if you think about
poker, which is
zero sum, how these two problems
might have emerged, right?
Because looking at a
zero-sum game like poker,
you can see how that
pattern happens.
So if I'm trying to offload
my bad results to luck
and I lose a hand
specifically to you,
I can't say that you won
the hand because of skill.
That doesn't work.
So I have to say that you
lost the hand because of luck,
because I'm trying to
put my bet-- you know,
I'm trying to say
it's bad luck for me.
So therefore, it must
be good luck for you.
And if I win a hand
because of skill,
rather, I can't say that
you lost because of luck.
It doesn't jive.
It's just that, you know, so we
sort of treat everything like
it's zero sum when we shouldn't.
But you can see how that
happens when I specifically
think I'm referring to you when
you're in my reference group,
right?
So again, how do
we solve for this?
Well, I'm going to go
back to that group idea.
Form a really, really
good decision group
that has different values.
So there's different ways that
we can derive good feelings
from ourselves, right?
So our natural tendency is to
try to offload it in the moment
so that we don't have to
have a negative update
to our self-image,
and we don't ever
miss out on a positive update
to our self-image, right?
Because if I say that I
won because I got lucky,
I don't get that
positive update.
And if I say that I lost
because of something I did,
I don't get that
positive update.
And that's sort
of the natural way
that we're, like,
getting our pellets.
Like, we're pressing a
lever in a Skinner box.
That's where our
pellets are coming from.
But very early in
my poker career,
I went up to somebody
named Eric Seidel, who's
an amazing poker player.
He's won over $38
million in his career,
so he's really, really good.
I had met him when
I was actually 16,
and I didn't start playing poker
professional till I was 26.
So he was just like
a buddy of mine.
And then all of
the sudden, I'm 26,
and now he's a
professional peer.
So I remember, I
was in a tournament
and I got knocked out.
And obviously, something
unlucky happened to me, clearly.
[LAUGHTER]
And I went up to Eric
Seidel, and I went
to go-- what's called moaning.
I went to go complain to him.
Oh, I can't believe this.
I had such bad luck.
I had this hand.
Meh, meh, meh.
The normal.
And he actually laid
this out for me,
how do we solve for this
in the most beautiful way?
It's going to sound
kind of brutal,
but I'm so thankful for it.
So why are you telling me this?
Like, you think I'm
not losing myself?
Like, why are you offloading
your negative emotions onto me?
I don't need that.
If you really lost
because of bad luck,
there's nothing to
be learned from it.
So I would like you to not
offload your emotional distress
onto me, thank you very much.
However, if you have a
question, if there's something
that you're trying to ask me
about strategy, I'm all ears.
So let's think about
what he did there.
He said, if you're not focusing
on accuracy, I don't care.
What does that mean,
this focus on accuracy?
Let's think about the
division between--
the distinction
between reasoning
to be accurate and
reasoning to be right.
Reasoning to be right is, I
just want my priors to be right.
So I'm just going to reason
to prove that I'm right
all the time, right?
Reasoning to be accurate--
that's funny that I said right
right after that--
reasoning to be
accurate is I'm trying
to construct the most accurate
model of the objective truth.
And if you think
about who's going
to win in a bet, the person
who's reasoning to be right
versus the person who's
reasoning to be accurate,
that's why when I say to
you, do you want to bet,
it takes you out of
the right mode right
into the accurate mode.
Because everybody understands
if I'm going to bet on it,
I'd better be reasoning
to be accurate.
So he told me, you have to
be reasoning to be accurate.
What you're doing right now
is reasoning to be right.
You're sad you lost.
It's not your fault.
Blah, blah, blah.
That doesn't help anybody.
But if you have a
question, if you
want to know whether you
accurately played the hand,
let's talk about it.
So he told me that I have to
think about accuracy if I'm
talking to him.
He told me he was going to
hold me accountable to that.
Because he did in that moment.
He was holding me accountable
to the way I was thinking.
And he said, you're
going to have
to be open to maybe
things aren't the way
that you want them to be.
So I was going to have to
be open to diverse opinions
and other people's perspectives.
So let's take those three
things as a great group charter,
right?
You have to have a focus
on accuracy, a commitment
to accuracy.
You have to hold each other
accountable to these things,
and you have to be open
to diverse viewpoints.
That seems like a
pretty good charter.
And what's really
wonderful about what Eric
did for me in that moment--
we remain friends, because
I was thankful for this.
I was a little upset in the
moment, but I got over it.
I saw the value eventually.
But what he did for
me was two things.
One is now I understood that
when I went and talked to him,
he was going to mentor me.
He was going to
teach me how to play.
So when I had hand questions, I
could actually deconstruct them
with him, and that was going
to be super helpful for me.
So that was a little
bit of the help.
But the big help he
gave me was when I
went back and played on my own.
So when you're playing
poker, it's all on your own.
I was processing what was
happening at the table
differently.
So I'm not processing,
oh, I got unlucky.
Oh, I'm so smart.
Oh, I got unlucky.
Because that's not good material
for me to go back to Eric with,
right?
And I know later on, he's
going to hold me accountable.
And if I want to have a really
good discussion with him,
I have to come to him
with good material.
So now it changes
the way that I'm
viewing what's happening
at the table in the moment
so that I'm looking
for mistakes.
I'm looking for questions.
I'm looking for where other
people might be outplaying me,
where they might be
winning because they're
better than I am.
And I'm going to go tell him.
And now this is what happens.
This is so great.
Two great things
happened from that.
Thing number one, I go back to
him and I say, you know what?
I think I really
butchered a hand.
I think I really made a mistake.
And he gives me a pellet, right?
So he wasn't giving me
pellets for pressing the,
I just got unlucky lever.
Right?
He's giving me pellets for the,
I think I made a mistake lever.
So that's really great.
So now that becomes part of
my self-narrative, right?
Eric Seidel wants to talk to me.
He thinks I'm smart, right?
So I'm not, like--
I practice mindfulness,
but I don't
think I'm ever achieving, like,
on the mountain in Tibet, not
worried about what the
world thinks of me.
I'm trying, but I'm
not going to get there.
So Eric Seidel is
giving me that, right?
He's helping me to think
better by giving me
the right kind of pellet, right?
That's number one.
And then number two,
again, back to the,
I'm trying to be a monk on
top of a mountain in Tibet,
I'm really trying hard for
that, that ultimate mindfulness
practice, but I'm I'm
kind of failing at it,
but I'm working on it.
I'm trying.
I'm practicing it.
But in the meantime, if we
go back to that tribalism,
and how does our tribe
feel distinct from others,
think about what it did
for me when I walked up
to Eric in my group
and I was saying,
oh, I really think
I made a mistake?
But when I'm walking down
the hall of the poker room,
I'm hearing all these
people go, can you
believe how unlucky I got?
Yeah, I got so unlucky too.
Yeah.
Oh, that guy's an idiot.
Da, da, da, da, da.
And that's what
those tribes, how
they're talking to each other.
So I got my distinctiveness
in the mix too.
So it's like I got my cake
and I got to eat it too,
which was kind of good.
And then in the meantime, I'm
doing a mindfulness practice
and trying not to worry
about any of that.
But until I can't-- you
know, until I get there,
I get to reinforce all of these
good changes in cognitive style
through what the
group is giving me.
SPEAKER 1: So I want to
ask you one more question
before I go to the audience.
It seems like what
you're talking about
is not just applicable
to the poker world.
ANNIE DUKE: No.
It's for sure not.
SPEAKER 1: I see the
investment world,
I see family, things like that.
Where have you seen these skills
kind of spill over for you
in your life?
ANNIE DUKE: Oh my gosh.
Everywhere.
So I want to say two things.
One is these skills
have definitely
spilled over in all areas of my
life, and I'm terrible at them.
So the thing is, the way that we
process information is so built
in that your goal is really to
be a little bit better at it.
And if you're a little
bit better at it,
it's going to
compound over time.
It's going to really
make a difference
in your overall decision quality
and the quality of the outcomes
that you eventually have.
So I still mess up all
the time, trust me.
Bad things happen to me.
I go, oh, I can't believe that.
I was so unlucky.
It's just that I
catch myself hopefully
more often, and hopefully
a little bit faster
than I otherwise would.
But I know I'm still
missing a lot of those.
I mean, I'm still biased.
So that's number one.
But number two in terms of areas
of my life, like everywhere.
So in the way that
I parent my children
and the way that I talk to my
partner and the way that I--
the process of writing this
book where you have to be--
like, you're working
with an editor,
and you have to not
sort of push off
what they're saying
because you feel
so much ownership
over the words,
and you know better
than they do.
It's like, trying to
have open-mindedness,
and really use the
editor and your agent,
and so on and so forth as that
kind of truth-seeking group
that you're trying to
come up with the best
representation of your ideas.
And that's not
necessarily all the ideas
of how you think it
should be presented.
You have to be
open-minded to that.
You know, like I say,
like in terms of the way
that I talk to my kids
and I guide my kids,
you know, every teenager
that I've raised
comes back from school.
I can't believe I did
so bad on the test.
It's because the
teacher was mean
and they gave me things
that they didn't even
teach in class, and
it was really hard.
And you can ask anybody.
Right?
So how are you talking
to somebody about that?
And you know, well,
with kids, you
don't want to be challenging
them in the same way.
But you say, OK.
I'm sorry about that.
So what are you going
to do about that?
Like, in the future,
how do you think
you're going to solve for that?
So really trying to
get them to understand,
what are the things that are
under your control and what
aren't?
So not in an Eric Seidel
way, but trying to say, OK.
How can you do better?
Like, how can you make
it so that-- maybe you
should go talk to the
teacher before the next test
if you know they might
put things on the test
that they didn't teach.
So you know, not so much
disagreeing with them,
because they're not adults.
But trying to get them to
focus more on those things that
are in their control.
But also just in terms of
when I was writing the book,
I was thinking, like, OK.
It's going to be a
certain amount of time
that I'm going to
have to invest.
You know, what am I
going to get in return?
What does the future look like?
Like, I thought about, the
book could be a total flop.
I have to think about
that in advance.
And is that going
to feel OK for me?
Is it going to be worthwhile
to have written the book,
even if nobody ever reads it?
So it's really
kind of everywhere.
And then really recognizing--
the other thing is, I'm a big
believer in Ulysses contracts,
because I really understand
that as much as you--
SPEAKER 1: Sorry, what
are Ulysses contracts?
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah.
Sorry.
You're right.
I'm assuming.
So a Ulysses
contract is thinking
in advance about
places where you
know you're going
to be really biased,
and it's going to be hard
to overcome this in order
to kind of prevent yourself
from acting irrationally.
So we don't always have a
group of other people around us
to help us.
But you can actually form a
different kind of group, which
is a group of the
past versions of you
and the future versions of you
to all kind of come together
and help the present
version of you.
So the classic example
is from Greek literature.
Odysseus was sailing
along, and he
knew he was going to come
to the island of the sirens.
And the sirens were
these beautiful nymphs
that sang on the
shore, and the song
was so irresistible
to the ears of any man
that they would steer their
ship toward the shore.
The shore was a rocky shoal
that would break the ship apart.
Sudden death.
So Ulysses, which is the
Roman name for Odysseus,
knew this, and asked his
crew to tie his hands
to the mast of the ship.
So this is a really good example
of forming a group that's
different versions of you.
So Odysseus said, future
Odysseus is really
going to have a problem,
because future Odysseus is going
to steer toward the shore.
So I'm going to tie
future Odysseus' hands
to stop him from doing that.
So I think there's
all sorts of places
where you can recognize that you
might need help in the future.
Like, a simple example would
be take a ride sharing service
to a bar.
That's a way to tie your hands.
For me with exercising, I
sign up for classes in advance
so that I've got my
schedule worked out
and I feel, you know, that
I have a commitment to that.
I only have certain kinds
of foods in the house.
You know, these are all
examples of Ulysses contracts.
And I'm a huge fan
of those, and I
apply those across
my whole life,
including actually in
writing the book, which
was instead of ever letting my
editor set the deadline for me,
because that is more like
someone telling me what to do,
which doesn't feel
like a contract,
I set all my own deadlines.
So I would tell her what day.
I actually would usually give
her three days and a confidence
interval around each one.
[LAUGHTER]
Because you know-- well,
obviously, because I
wrote this book.
So it would be with it.
But there would be
a week that I would
know that I had to turn it in.
And I would say, you
know, it's 60% on Monday
and 80% on Tuesday
and 98% on Friday.
So by setting that myself,
I was creating a contract.
And then I held to the
deadline and actually got
the book in early, because I
was applying Ulysses contracts.
So I really do practice
what I preach in the book.
SPEAKER 1: I think it's
an excellent concept,
and I'm just realizing, oh
my god, I didn't see that.
Because I was writing
a letter someone,
and I was making a reference
to the sirens and their songs.
So that's excellent.
Do we have any
audience questions?
Sure.
ANNIE DUKE: Let's
start here, because you
were my poker opponent.
And then I'll move
across the line.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Annie, it's great
to have you here.
My wife is a big fan.
ANNIE DUKE: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I come from China.
Just [INAUDIBLE]
your career pathway's
very kind of interesting
from academia, then poker,
now reaching other causes.
So what kind of--
you talk about these
[INAUDIBLE],, right?
Just for your life, based
on your life experience,
what kind of [INAUDIBLE]
those kind of--
what you [INAUDIBLE],,
you know, what do did,
you know, did you naturally
come to that decision,
or some time you
really think about
it [INAUDIBLE] block some time?
Oh, OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, that's basically--
ANNIE DUKE: Huh.
So that's an
interesting question.
So yeah.
I mean, I have taken
a lot of turns.
And I actually
think that my life
is a good example of
really understanding
kind of, you know, this luck
versus decision quality.
So I would say that the two
big careers that I've had
have come out of,
something happens
that either on the face of
it looks lucky or unlucky,
but it's definitely an
intervention of luck.
And then I just say, OK.
Here I am.
Now let me think about where
I'm going to go from here.
So it's not sort of
sitting and wallowing
in the sort of luck element
of it, but just thinking, OK.
I'm here now, so now, all right.
That's done.
I've got to figure out
where to go from here.
So the first one would be
this illness that landed me
in the hospital for two weeks.
I still sometimes
struggle with it,
but you know, it was very out
of control at that time, and now
I've got it under
control, so it doesn't
intervene in my life in
the same way anymore.
But this was when I was really
struggling with this stomach
issue.
I land in the hospital
for two weeks.
This seems like an
incredibly unlucky thing
that's happened to me.
And I say, OK.
I need money.
What am I going to do?
I don't have my
fellowship anymore.
It turns out that when
you leave graduate school
and take time off, the
National Science Foundation
doesn't still give you money.
So all right.
I've got to figure out
what I'm going to do,
and that's when I
started playing poker.
And then when I was playing
poker, I discovered, OK.
Like, I'm pretty good at
it and I really enjoy it,
and it seemed like this
really cool collision
of what I was
studying in academics
and sort of real life, right?
And at that point
I said, OK, I'm
just going to delay graduate
school, and this is what I did.
Once I started playing
poker, I didn't necessarily
think there was something
else I was going to do.
Then I got asked to
give this talk in 2002.
It was great, and I
still didn't think--
and that was a matter of luck,
because Eric Seidel actually
got asked to give the talk.
Not me.
And he hates public
speaking, so he referred me.
This had nothing to do with me.
I wasn't seeking it out, right?
This was not a decision I made.
I get offered the talk.
I say yes.
I give it, and I'm
still thinking, oh,
that was fun, except that the
people that I gave the talk to
started referring me out,
at which point I said, OK.
Now I've got a choice.
Maybe I could do this as well.
Which I did.
And there's been all
sorts of-- there's
other points in my life.
I almost became an options
trader a little while
after that, but then
poker got on TV,
and I thought that's
kind of interesting.
Maybe I'll try that.
And I think that because I think
probabilistically, I end up--
I'm just less likely to
stick with the status quo.
I'm more likely to say, OK.
It's a new decision.
Do I want to switch
grocery lines?
And so I think
that's sort of how
I end up looking kind
of here or here or here.
It's just, OK.
Luck brings you
to certain places,
and I'm perfectly fine
saying, here's the status quo
and here is this new
thing that I can do.
What can I do?
Or maybe I can do them
both at the same time.
I think I tend to be
more open-minded maybe
to that, because
that's the thing
that poker really teaches you.
It's like the best
laid plans, right?
You still lose the hand.
And so it forces you to
think probabilistically.
You have to be thinking this
way or you will not succeed.
And I think naturally,
it spreads out.
Here is the actual
funniest example
that I can give you of how
poker players just really think
this way.
So when I went to
go on my first date
with the absolute
love of my life,
my brother and
brother-in-law, who
both knew the person I was
going on the first date with,
immediately set a market.
[LAUGHTER]
So they started bidding.
We'd never been on a date.
We had been friends
for a long time,
but we'd never been on a date.
So they start bidding,
and my brother-in-law
ended up buying 23.
So somebody said to
me, aren't you offended
that they started
making a market?
And I was like, no.
I just can't believe my
brother-in-law bought 23.
Like, we'd never been on a date.
So I think that
that shows you, it's
just this way of thinking
about the world, just sort
of attaching numbers to it.
And that's why I think
that I've sort of--
I hope that answers
your question.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So our next question is online.
ANNIE DUKE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: You've
talked about feeling
like an imposter or outsider
at some poker tables.
What are some of the ways
the ideas in your book
can help address the
imposter syndrome sensation
or counteract overconfidence?
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah.
That's actually really good.
So I think the overconfidence
piece is a little bit easier
to deal with, because I think
that if you have a really
good decision
group, they're going
to check your overconfidence.
So that's going to be
part of the conversation
all the time is, are you
feeling overconfident?
Imposter syndrome, you
know, it's a hard one.
I mean, I feel it all the time.
I feel it about this book.
I feel it when I get
up and give talks.
It's like, ugh.
You know, why am I
even opening my mouth?
And I think that, again,
it's like, get other people
to talk to you, because
what they can do
is they can often see
things more clearly.
So I've actually had
conversations where I've said,
you know, oh, I just
feel like this--
I can't believe it.
I'm such an imposter.
I don't know what I'm
talking about, da, da, da.
And people will
say, like, people
keep hiring you for speeches.
They'll actually go through it.
Like, you know,
they refer you out.
People are buying your book.
They're obviously-- you know.
And having other people to
kind of look at you in a more
objective way to get you
out of your own head,
I really feel like
that's the way to do it.
And then what happens
is it's like--
I highly recommend everybody
read "The Power of Habit,"
because it really shows you
how to change your habits.
But not just the habits
of, like, going to the gym.
Like, your habits of mind
and the way you think.
And what ends up is--
you know, remember
I said when I had that
conversation with Eric Seidel,
now when I went to the table,
I was thinking about what
Eric Seidel might say later.
And so when you have a really
good decision group that's
checking your bias, whether
it's overconfidence or
underconfidence or
imposter syndrome,
the group gets in your
head in a really good way.
So that then when I'm sort
of on my own and I'm like--
trust me, when I leave this
room and I'm in the car,
I'm going to think about
what a bad talk I gave.
So maybe I did.
I don't know.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
ANNIE DUKE: So now
I'm in my head.
OK.
So anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
--when I do that, hopefully
I have a group of people
that I can sort of
offload that to,
and they can offload
things like that to me.
And hopefully,
they're talking to me.
I mean, not physically.
But I'm sort of running
that conversation, you know?
Because that's really what
happened at the poker table
was if I was
processing the world
in a way that was
irrational, I would
run the conversation with Eric
or my brother or John Hennigan,
or whoever it might be later
where they were telling me,
like, oh, come on.
And that would help me when
I was kind of on my own.
So I think it's about, what
are the rewards you're getting?
And how are people around
you helping to sort of shape
those habits of mind?
And I think that's
really the best way,
because I think it's just--
the thing is, I think it's
so hard to do on your own.
I think we all really need
help with this, you know?
And I think another
mistake we make
is we think, well, if I know
about it, like, if I know
about imposter syndrome or
I know about overconfidence
and I'm really smart,
problem solved.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: In the
book, didn't you
mention that the people who
have the highest IQ scores
are the ones you're
most susceptible to--
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah.
So high IQ correlates positively
with motivated reasoning.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--right.
And you can think
why that is, right?
It's like, how do you
slice and dice the info?
Like, if you're
cognitively agile,
you're going to be
able to slice and dice
a story that sounds a lot
more convincing to yourself
and to others about why
everything you believe is true,
and why every prediction
you ever have is 100%.
So yeah.
So I'm smart and I know about
this now is not necessarily
a solution.
And like I say, I'm
telling you, I'm
going to walk away
from this and I'm
going to think about
what a bad job I did.
I don't want you guys to think
that you practice these things
and somehow it's ever solved.
It's not.
It's just, do I catch
myself doing it more often?
Do I do it less?
And those-- just doing it less
and catching it more often,
it's huge.
So instead of berating
yourself for all the times
that you screw up, it's
like you get to celebrate
that I did it one fewer times.
You know?
Like it's such a more
self-compassionate way to live.
And I'm really-- like,
I'm trying to get there.
But you know, yeah.
So I think you had a question.
Yeah?
Oh, sorry.
Were we supposed to end?
I'm sorry.
I didn't want to--
SPEAKER 1: No, we're good.
Keep going.
Yeah.
ANNIE DUKE: We're OK?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
ANNIE DUKE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Short question.
What's your strategy
for rock paper scissors?
ANNIE DUKE: Oh.
Short answer is throw scissors.
[LAUGHTER]
So just kind of understand-- so
most people throw rock first,
and then most people kind
of know you throw rock.
So what happens is--
well, it depends.
If you're against somebody
who is a total newbie,
so you know they're
going to throw rock,
then you should
just throw paper.
But if you're against
somebody who you think
is a little bit smarter
than that, they're
going to throw paper on you,
so you do a pretty good job
throwing scissors.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNIE DUKE: And if
they're really good,
they throw scissors and you
tie, so it's not a big deal.
AUDIENCE: One of
the things that you
said at the beginning
of the talk really stuck
with me about talking about
your opinions in terms of bets
and challenging that.
How do you do that when
something isn't quite as
quantifiable as the
number of representatives
in the house in November?
ANNIE DUKE: Sure.
So everything can be quantified.
The chances that you--
because everything
is probabilistic.
Like, the chances that you meet
the love of your life tomorrow
or that the person that
you stay with, you'll still
be with in 10 years,
or whether you're
going to like the dish that
you order at a restaurant,
or literally, everything
is quantifiable.
Now do we have enough data
to get to flipping heads
or tails where we
know 50% of the time
that you're going to flip heads?
No.
Is there some objective
probability for anything?
Sure.
Do we have access to it?
Absolutely not.
But we can come up with a range.
So what people will
say to me is often,
well, it's not
really quantifiable.
Well, of course it is.
It's just that there's
more unknown information.
It's harder to get to.
We don't have as much data.
So what I tell them is, look.
Let's say that I were to ask you
some question about, well, what
do you think the chances are
that this belief that you have
is true, and the
best you could do
is somewhere
between 20% and 80%.
That's a really wide market.
But you know what?
It's not as wide as 0% to 100%.
Like, at least you're trying.
That's the thing.
So even if you
say, I don't know,
I can narrow it down
to between 20% and 80%,
that's not a failure.
That's a success,
because you're trying.
And then what that does is
because you say, well, OK,
it's 20% to 80%,
man, I'd really like
to try to refine that, you'll
now start to go ask people.
Like, you're going to go
start asking for information.
Whereas if you just
sort of leave it as,
like, whatever,
you don't actually
ever try to get better at it.
So now maybe you go and
you start researching.
You know what?
I make a joke in literally
every single talk that I give.
I say, what this does for you is
it makes you take out and look
at Google.
You guys will be very happy.
But literally, it's a joke
in every talk that I give.
It makes you want
to Google things.
But it makes you want
So now you start Googling,
and maybe you say, oh, OK.
Now I'm narrowed down.
It's between 72% and--
right.
So like, that's what
happens, you know?
Now it's 72-28.
And now you're a little
bit narrower than 80-20.
And that's all
we're trying to do.
But if we don't think about
things probabilistically,
if we don't
recognize that what's
going to happen in the
future is probabilistic,
that we can't guarantee it,
we are not playing chess.
If I play better than you,
it does not mean I win.
Not in life.
Only in chess.
Right?
If we don't do that,
then we're going
to be really surprised
when a bad outcome happens.
We're going to overreact to it.
We're going to start changing
strategy when we shouldn't.
We're going to reinforce
strategies that we shouldn't.
We're going to always
be reacting instead
of planning ahead, instead
of being proactive,
because we're not understanding
that, well, other things could
happen than the thing
that we think, you know?
So I think just try.
Because literally,
everything's quantifiable.
SPEAKER 1: Where were you
at Black Friday in 2011?
And what are your thoughts
on regulating online poker?
ANNIE DUKE: Oh.
OK, that's an
interesting question.
So I remember this.
I was in my bedroom,
and I got a call.
You should open up the
internet, and you should look.
So Black Friday is the
DOJ came down and shut
down all of online poker.
It was a very bad day for poker.
Everybody was really mad.
It was really hard.
Like, in a lot of ways,
the poker community
hasn't recovered from it.
So it was kind of interesting,
because I played in '90s,
and poker money was not
raining down from the sky.
There was a very small group
of people who were playing,
and then you'd
sometimes have someone
who came in and would play.
And you know, it was
really like you were--
it was called grinding.
And then online poker happened
with the collision of poker
on TV, and the poker
economy just boomed.
I mean, boomed.
It was really just money
raining down from the sky.
And then the DOJ
on Black Friday--
now it all contracts.
And that was really hard.
I think it was less
hard for the people who
had been playing in the '90s,
because I think we sort of saw
the luck in what had happened
during the 2000s a little bit
more.
But it's like, whenever anything
goes through a big recession--
and I would call
it a depression--
it's painful.
Like, it's super, super,
super, super painful.
You know, in terms of whether
there should be regulation,
you know, I'm somewhat small
government, but I'm also--
I like people to
have protections.
So I did testify in
front of Congress
twice about
regulation, and I tend
to be more on the sort of free,
freer side of that discussion,
you know, that you should
let adults choose what they
want to do, and then
obviously make sure
that there isn't fraud
occurring, right?
So you should always have
protections against fraud.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: What
resonated with me,
you questioned the status quo.
I think it's great, because it
gives you a lot of opportunity
to see options in life all
the time instead of just
going with what you have.
But also, I have the feeling
it's a risky business,
you know?
You can invest a lot of time in
always questioning your status
quo.
And instead of focusing on
what you're doing and trusting
your decisions you
made in the past.
And how do you find
the balance, you know?
And you seem to have been
going good places with it.
So do you set yourself,
you know, [INAUDIBLE]??
Oh, I'm questioning where I'm
at in life next month from now?
Or do you two minutes later
when you're on the wrong line?
I mean, you know, how much
time do you invest in that?
It's a bet too.
ANNIE DUKE: I think
there's a couple things.
I think certainly from
a business standpoint,
we always go--
you know, there's always
strategic planning sessions.
And I think that
when we do that,
it's always around,
what's the new decision?
And what doesn't get included
in there is, well, what about
sticking with what we're doing?
So I think that we tend to get
involved in strategic planning
decisions generally when
there's something wrong,
and you should actually set
a calendar for, all right.
Let's start thinking about, what
are our goals, regardless of
whether we think something is
wrong, because maybe there's
a better way to do it.
And actually, working
backwards is--
so something called
backcasting and pre-mortems is
the best way to do that.
So imagine what your goal is.
Think about that you've
actually reached it.
This is a backcast.
And then think about
how you actually did it.
So it's three years from
now and we accomplished X.
How did we do that?
But then also a pre-mortem
is, it's three years from now
and we failed.
You know, how did that happen?
And I think that allows you to
see the landscape a little bit
better.
What I would say in terms
of, are you doing it too much
or are you doing it too
little, there's two things
that I want to say about that.
One is that I
certainly don't think
that every decision
is supposed to be
done as a deliberative process.
If you did that, I wouldn't be
able to get from here to there,
right?
So a lot of stuff
that's happening
is certainly more gut, and
it's more in the moment.
And I think that
that's totally fine, as
long as you hold your intuition
accountable to a deliberative
process at some point.
So when somebody
says to you, well,
why did you do what you did,
your answer should never be,
because my gut told me to.
And then when they
say, OK, that's great,
but why, it shouldn't be, I told
you, because my gut told me to.
If you can't teach it to another
person, there's a problem.
So that being said,
I think intuition
can be very good
as long as you're
checking it occasionally.
But in terms of whether
you should have a schedule,
I think once you start
thinking about the world more
probabilistically,
you're naturally
examining those things.
And it's happening
relatively automatically,
and you do end up sticking
with the status quo a lot.
It's just that you're sort of
seeing these opportunities over
on the side more.
Now what's interesting
is that when
you do that, you
don't just overreact,
and just because things
aren't going well right now,
you're actually less likely,
I think, to change course.
Because I think that a
lot of our changing course
is a reaction to the way
that the status quo is now.
It's a reaction to
having a bad outcome.
And a lot of not changing
course is that we just
happen to have good outcomes.
So I think that what happens
is that when you start
thinking in this way
more probabilistically,
even if you have good
outcomes, you're always
sort of working with
your decision group of,
like, well, is
there a better way?
That doesn't necessarily
mean you do it.
It just means it's in
your head so that you're
more likely to see
the opportunity when
it comes your way.
But what's more
important is you're
less likely to overreact
to a bad outcome happening
where you actually
change course too much.
And I would actually say
that interestingly enough,
that that second problem is
what the bigger problem is.
It's not so much that
if you think this way,
you're going to be going left,
right, left, right, left,
right.
It's that you're not
going to be just going
left because bad things
are happening all the time.
You're going to be setting back
into a more deliberative place
on those things that's
actually going to either cause
you to make sort of
incremental changes
that are going to
be really good,
it's going to cause you to be
able to anticipate or think
about paradigm shifts
yourself a little bit better.
And I think it's going
to actually give you
a smoother ride much more
so than a less smooth ride.
I don't know.
See now you might go and
say, no, she should actually
get into that limo.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: No, I mean, it
was good to hear your view
on the other side [INAUDIBLE].
So I'd like to hear that too.
ANNIE DUKE: Yeah, no,
I'm all for status quo.
AUDIENCE: Once you start
doing it, you see the success,
and you are always
questioning your decisions
you made yesterday, right?
ANNIE DUKE: Well, yeah.
So I think it's like--
again, it has to do-- right.
It has to do with
separating those--
don't pat yourself--
I sort of say,
don't get so down on yourself
for your bad outcomes,
and don't pat yourself
on the back so hard
for your good ones.
So here's a really
great way, actually,
to implement within
your own life.
It's like, once a week,
have your team get together.
Each person presents
the best success
that they had that week, and
everybody talks about, like,
they have to offer
up the five things
that they did wrong along
the way to that success.
So it's not about
changing course, right?
It's more about refining,
about always trying
to do a little bit better.
And I think that when you
have that goal in mind,
I think you do a lot better.
Because otherwise, what makes
us make these big left turns?
I mean, I've got a
couple in my life.
But you know, what makes us make
these big left turns, I think,
is when we're
reacting to the way
that things are--
we're just reacting.
So when you're trying to
separate those two things out
and always be trying to focus
on process, now what happens
is you're less likely to be
making these 90-degree changes,
I think.
SPEAKER 1: I have
an online question.
What is your approach to
the mental game of poker
when running bad, when our
emotions can potentially
influence our thought process?
Can you compare
that to the advice
offered by Jared Tendler and his
popular "Mental Game of Poker"
books?
ANNIE DUKE: OK, so I
haven't read those books,
so I can't make the comparison.
But I can answer the first
part of the question.
OK.
So there's something in
poker called tilt. Tilt is
when our emotions get lit up.
That shuts your
frontal cortex down,
and we start making
really bad decisions.
So I say, poker has this really
interesting quality of you're
exchanging chips
every single hand.
And so it's letting
you see that there's
risk in every single decision.
So that's the good thing.
The bad thing is it's allowing
you to get caught in the path,
right?
So if you think about
it, I mean, obviously,
what we'd really like
is to think of ourselves
as a Berkshire
Hathaway stock, right?
We want a general upward
trend to our happiness stock
over our lifetime.
And if you look at
Berkshire Hathaway
from the moment
of its inception,
it has that general
upward trend,
and it looks like a
pretty nice little ride.
But if you look at
it on a given day,
it might have a sharp downturn.
And in poker, because
you've got this exchange
happening all the
time, you end up
doing what's called
ticker watching,
and you can really
see those downswings,
feel those upswings.
And so you start getting
yanked around in this kind
of path-dependent--
you know, you're very
path-dependent in terms
of where your emotions are.
And this is generally a
problem in life, right?
So as an example, let's say that
you're on the side of the road
and you have a flat
tire, and it's raining
and it's really cold, and
you don't have a jack,
and you called AAA, and
you know they take forever.
And so you're just
cursing your life, right?
You're just thinking, like,
I have the unhappiest life.
I can't even imagine it.
Why do these things
always happen to me?
Ugh.
Do you think it matters if
yo got a promotion three days
before?
Are you like, now
hold on a second.
Let me actually take the
average of my happiness--
[LAUGHTER]
--over the last three days.
No.
It's like, literally
what happened
three days ago doesn't matter.
You're really deep
down in that moment.
So this actually gives us a
clue to how we deal with this,
and it's part of how poker
players deal with it.
So if I were to say
to you, OK, let's
say that you had that
flat tire a year ago,
do you think that
that would have
affected your happiness
one bit over the course
of the last year?
That one incident?
To tell you the truth, I
actually think it would.
I think it would uptick.
I think it would cause an
uptick in your happiness,
because it's a really
good cocktail party story.
Interesting articles that I've
seen, a lot of current events
and thinking about it in terms
of resulting or hindsight bias
or self-serving bias
or motivated reasoning
or whatever it might be
to really kind of look at,
what are the things
that are happening out
in the world that can help
us to try to figure out how
to be better decision makers?
So like this week, for
example, I talked a little bit
about the NFL draft and decision
making around the NFL draft.
I also talked about a really
interesting study that
was done on inducing
intellectual humility
in high school students, and
how that actually increases
their ability to
learn, to really get
into that sort of
mode of, I'm not sure.
So that was in there.
I talked about something
from [INAUDIBLE]
on the peak-end rule, and how
you can hack that in order
to make your memories better
and your experiences better,
or at least your memory of
your experiences better.
And then I'll also talk
about things that--
not in this particular
one, but last week,
I think I talked
about current events,
things that are
happening in politics,
and that kind of thing.
So hopefully, people will
subscribe to the newsletter.
You can actually find
archives of the newsletter
on annieduke.com.
So you don't have to buy
it until you actually
test the product.
So you can go see--
SPEAKER 1: And when are
you starting your podcast?
[LAUGH]
Because I think you'd do
a great job doing that.
ANNIE DUKE: Well,
I appreciate that.
So I'm not-- so I've
had that suggestion.
I'm thinking about it.
Right now because of
the launch of the book,
I'm doing a lot of
podcasts, and so I'm
kind of enjoying
that at the moment.
I've done some really,
really fun ones.
And actually, it's exposed
me to a bunch of podcasts
that I didn't know about,
so that's been actually
super fun is that I'm getting
to find out about some podcasts
that I wasn't
personally aware of.
I love podcasts,
because I think--
I mean, some of them are
obviously like, you know,
your 15-minute deals.
But the ones that are
more like this where
you get to do a deep dive.
And then what I find that's
so amazing about them
is that I rarely come
away from a podcast where
I haven't learned something.
I mean, not just
one thing either.
Like, so much where you get to
sit and talk to somebody who's
obviously really smart
and really engaged,
and see what their perspective
on your product is, is so cool.
And it's just like, such
gratitude for how it changed--
like, you come in and
you're like, well,
this is my work product.
And then you come away
going, oh my gosh.
Like, I didn't think of that,
and I was so challenged,
and that makes me think
about it in a different way.
And oh, this relates
to this in a way
that I hadn't thought before.
So I'm just enjoying
that process right now,
and then we'll see.
I don't know.
We'll see what the future holds
in terms of anything else.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Well, if you haven't
already, grab her book.
It's called "Thinking in
Bets: Making Smarter Decisions
When You Don't Have
All the Facts."
If we can give her, please,
a huge round of applause.
ANNIE DUKE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]